to our best understanding today
how deadly is coveted
do we have a good measure
for for this very question
so the the best evidence for covet the
deadlines of covet comes from a whole
series of sierra prevalence studies
sierra province studies are these
studies of
antibody prevalence in the population at
large
i was
part of the you know the very first set
of sierra problem studies one in santa
clara county one in l.a county and one
in the with major league baseball around
the u.s
uh if i may just pause you for a second
if people don't know what uh serology is
in several prevalence it does sound like
you say zero prevalence it's not it's
zero and serology's antibodies so it's
it's a survey that counts the number of
antibodies specifically
people that have antibodies
specific to covaid which perhaps shows
an indication that they likely have had
covet and therefore this is a way to
study how many people in the population
have been exposed to have had
exactly yeah exactly so the idea is that
we don't know
exactly the number of people with
covered just by counting the people that
are there to present themselves with
symptoms of covet um covet has it turns
out a very wide range of symptoms
possible for ranging from no symptoms at
all
to this deadly viral pneumonia that's
killed so many people
and the problem is like in if you just
count the number of cases the people who
have very few symptoms
often don't show up for testing we just
don't they're outside of the can of of
public health
and so it's really hard to know
the the answer to your question without
understanding how many people are
infected because you you can probably
tell the number of deaths that's even
though there's some controversy over
that but uh that so that the numerator
is possible but the denominator is much
harder how much controversy is there
about the death we're gonna go on
million tangents is that
okay we're gonna i have a million
questions so one
i love data so much
but i've like almost tuned out paying
attention to kova data because i feel
like i'm walking on shaky ground i don't
know who to trust
maybe you can comment on different
sources of data different kinds of data
the death one that seems like a really
important one
can we trust the reported deaths
associated with covid or is it just a
giant messy thing that mixed up and then
there's this kind of stories about
hospitals being incentivized
uh to report a death as covet death so
uh uh there's some truth in some of that
let me just so
let me just talk about the incentive so
in the united states
we passed this cares act that was aimed
at
making sure hospital assistance didn't
go bankrupt in the early days the
pandemic
the couple things they did one was they
provided incentives to treat covet
patients tens of thousands of dollars
extra per per covered patient
um and the other thing they did is they
they gave a 20 bump to medicare payments
for elderly patients who are treated
with covet the idea is that there's more
expensive to treat them i guess the
early days
um so that did provide an incentive to
sort of have have a lot of code patients
in the hospital because your financial
success of the hospital or at least not
lack of financial ruin depended on
having many coveted patients the other
thing on the death certificates is that
reporting of deaths is a separate issue
i don't know that there's a financial
incentive there but there is this sort
of like complicated you know when you
fill out a death certificate
for a patient with a lot of conditions
uh like let's say a patient has diabetes
a patient that well that diabetes could
lead to to
uh heart failure you know you have a
heart attack heart failure your lungs
fill up then you get covered
and
what and you die so what do you what do
you write on the death certificate was
it because the cover that killed you was
it the lungs filling up was it the the
heart heart failure was it the diabetes
it's really difficult to like
disentangle
um and i think a lot of a lot of times
what's happened is they people have like
erred on the side of signing it's covet
now what's the evidence of this uh
there's been a couple of
of audits of death certificates in
places like santa clara county where i
live in alameda county
uh california where they they carefully
went through the death certificate said
okay is this reasonable to say this was
actually covered or is this was covalent
incidental and they found that about 25
20 25 of the deaths were
more likely incidental than directly due
to covet
i personally don't get too excited about
this i mean it's a philosophical
question right like ultimately
what kills you
which is an odd thing to say if you if
you're if you're don't you're not in
medicine but like really it's it's a
it's almost always multifactorial it's
always always just the bus hits you the
bus hits you that you get a brain bleed
was the brain bleed that killed you
would it burst anyway i mean you know
the bus hit you killed you right the way
you die is a philosophical question but
it's also a sociological and
psychological question because it seems
like
every single person who's passed away
over the past couple years kind of the
first question that comes to mind was
just was it not not just because you're
trying to be political but just in your
mind no i think there's a psychological
reason for this right so um
you know we have we spent uh the better
part of a at least a half century in the
united states not worried too much
about infectious diseases and we the
notion was we'd essentially conquered
them it was something that happens in
far away places to other people
and that's true for much of the
developed world life expectancies were
going up for you know decades and
decades
and for the first time in living memory
we have a disease that can kill us
i mean i think we're
effectively evolved to fear that like
the the panic centers of our brain the
lizard part of our brain takes over
and our central focus has been avoiding
this one risk
um and so it's not surprising that but
people when they're filling out death
certificates or thinking about what what
led to the death this most salient thing
that's in the front of everyone's brain
would jump to the top
and we can't ignore
this very deep psychological thing when
we consider
what people say on the internet what
people say to each other what people
write in scientific papers what
everything it feels like
when kovid
has been um
has been brought onto this world
everything changed in the way people
feel about each other just the way they
communicate with each other
i think
the the level of emotion involved
i think it in many people it brought out
the worst in them uh
for sometimes short periods of time and
sometimes it was always therapeutic like
you were waiting to get out like the
darkest parts of you
just to say if you're angry at something
in this world i'm going to say it now
and um i think that's probably talking
to some deep primal thing that
um
fear we have for um
formalities of all different kinds and
then when that fear is aroused and all
the deepest emotions it's like a
freudian
uh psychotherapy session but across the
world it's something that uh
psychologists are gonna have a field day
with for generation trying to understand
um i mean i think that i think what you
say is right but piled on top of that is
also this sort of
uh this impetus to empathy to empathize
compassion toward others
essentially
militarized right so i'm protecting you
by by some actions
and
uh those actions if i if i don't do them
if you don't do them well that months
must mean you don't yes you you hate me
it's created this like social tension
that i've never seen before and we and
we start have started we started we
looked at each other as if we were just
simply
sources of of germs
rather than people to get to know
people to enjoy people to get you know
to learn from um it it colored basically
almost every human interaction for every
every human on the planet
yeah the basic common humanity it's like
you can wear a mask you can stand far
away
but the
love you have for each other when you
look into each other's eyes that was
dissipating and
by region too i've experienced having
traveled quite a bit throughout this
time
it um it was really sad even people that
are really close together just the way
they stood the way they looked at each
other
and i it made me feel for a moment
um
that the fabric that connects all of us
is more fragile than i thought
i mean if you walk down the street or if
you ever if you did this during covet
i'm sure you had this experience where
you walk down the street if you're not
wearing a mask or even if you are people
will jump off the off the sidewalk as
you walk past them
as if your poison
even though the data are that covet
spreads you know indifferently outdoors
or if at all really it outdoors
but it's not simply a biological or
infectious disease phenomenon or
immunological it is a it is a it's a
it is a change in the way humans treated
each other i hope hope temporary
i i do want to say on the flip side of
that so i was
mostly in boston massachusetts when the
pandemic broke out i think that's where
i was yeah
and then i got came here to austin texas
to visit my now good friend joe rogan
and he was the first person
without pause this wasn't a political
statement this was anything just walk
toward me and give me a big hug
and say it's great to see you and i
can't tell you how great it felt because
i in that moment realized the absence of
that connection back in boston over just
a couple of
over a couple of months and um
it's we'll talk about it more but it's
it's tragic to think about
that distancing that dissolution of
common humanity at scale what what kind
of impact it has on society just
across the board political division
uh and just in the quiet of your own
mind in the privacy of your own home the
depression the sadness the loneliness
that leads to suicide
and forget suicide just
low-key suffering yeah no i think that's
that's the suffering that isolation
we're not meant to live alone we're not
meant to live apart from one another
that's of course the ideology of
lockdown is to make people live apart
alone isolated so that we don't spread
diseases to each other right
but we're not actually designed as a
species to live that way
and that uh what you're describing i
think
if everyone's honest with themselves
have felt
especially in places where that where
lockdowns have been sort of very
militantly enforced has felt deep into
their core
well i if i could just return to the
question of deaths
he said that the data isn't perfect
because we need these kind of uh serial
prevalence surveys to understand how
many cases there were to determine the
rate of deaths and we need to have a
strong footing in the number of deaths
but if we assume that the the the number
of deaths is approximately correct
like what's your sense what kind of
statements
can we say about the deadliness of covet
against
across different demographics maybe not
in a political way or in the current way
but when history looks back
at this moment of time 50 years from now
100 years from now the way we look at
the
pandemic 100 years ago
what will they say about the deadlines
of code i mean i think uh the deadliest
of cova depends on not just the virus
itself but who who it infects
um so the probably the most important
thing about it about the deadlines of
covet is is this steep age gradient in
the mortality rate um so according to
these zero prevalence studies that that
that have been done now hundreds of them
um
mostly from before vaccinations
vaccination also reduces the mortality
risk of covid
the the sierra prevalent studies suggest
that uh the risk of of death if you're
say over the age of 70
is
very high if you have five percent
if you get covered
if you're if you're under the age of 70
it's lower uh 0.05 but there's not a
single sharp cutoff it's more like i
have a rule of thumb that i use
so if you're 50
say the infection fatality rate from
cova is 0.2 percent according to the
sierra prevalence data
that means 99.8 survival
if you're 50 and for every 7 years of
age above that double it every 7 years
of age below that have it
so a 57 year old have a point four
percent
uh mortality a 64 year old would have a
point eight percent and so on and uh if
you have a severe chronic disease like
diabetes or if you're more morbidly
obese it's like adding seven seven years
to your life
and this is uh for unvaccinated folks
this is unvaccinated uh in the before
delta also
are there a lot of people that will be
listening to this with phds at the end
of their name that would disagree with
the 99.8 would you say
so i think there's some disagreement
over this uh and the disagreement
is about the quality of the serial
prevalence studies that that were
conducted
uh so as i said earlier i was a senior
investigator in three different circle
studies and very early in the epidemic
i view them as very high quality studies
um we we um in santa clara county what
we did is we used a a test kit
uh to
that we obtained from
someone who works in major league
baseball actually he ordered these test
kits very early in march 2020
that measures very accurately measures
antibody levels
or antibodies in the in in the
bloodstream
uh these test kits were eventually were
approved by the the the head of eua by
the emergency use authorization by the
fda sort of shortly after we did this
and uh it had a very low false positive
right false positive means if you if you
uh if you don't have these coveted
antibodies in your bloodstream the kit
shows up positive anyways that that
turns out to happen about point five
percent of the time
um
and uh based on studies uh a very large
number of studies looking at blood from
2018 you try it against this kit
and uh you know point five percent of
the time 2018 there shouldn't be any
bodies there so for to cover if it turns
positive as a false positive 0.5 percent
of the time
um and then you know like a false
negative rate uh about
ten percent twelve percent something
like that i don't remember exact number
but the false positive rate is the
important thing there right so you have
a population in march 2020 or april 2020
with very low
fraction of patients have been exposed
to code you don't know how much but low
even a small false positive rate could
end up
biasing your study quite a bit
but there's a formula to adjust for that
you can adjust for the fourth phosphate
rate false negative rate we did we did
that adjustment and those studies found
in a community population so leaving
aside people in nursing homes who have a
higher death rate from covid um the that
the death rate was 0.2 percent in santa
clara county
and in la county across all these groups
in the community community meaning just
like regular yeah so like that's
actually a real important question too
so the santa clara study we did this
facebook sampling scheme
um which is i mean not not the ideal
thing but it's like it was very
difficult to get a random sample and
during the you know during lockdown
um where we put out up an ad on facebook
soliciting people to
volunteer for the study randomly
selected set of people we were hoping to
get a random selection of people from
santa clara county but it tended to the
people who tend to volunteer were from
the richer parts of the county like i
had stanford professors writing begging
to be in the study because they wanted
antibody levels
so we did some adjustment for that in
l.a county we hired a firm that had a
pre-existing
representative sample of la county
um
so but it didn't include nursing homes
it didn't include people in jail things
like that didn't include the homeless
populations so it's it's representative
of a community dwelling population
both of those
and there we found that both in l.a
county and santa clara county in april
2020 something like 40 to 50 times more
infections than cases in both places
so for every case that had been reported
to the public health authorities we
found that you know you know 40 or 50
other infections people with antibodies
in their blood
that suggested that they'd had coveted
and recovered so people were not
reporting or severe at least in those
days under reporting yeah i mean there
was you know there's testing problems
there weren't so many tests available
people didn't know a lot of a lot of
them we asked a set of questions about
the symptoms they'd faced
and mostly said they faced no symptoms
or at the most uh 30 40 of the said face
their no symptoms
and i mean even these days how many
people report that they get coveted when
they get covered okay i'll have those
numbers
that point two percent has that
approximately held up over time that is
so if professor john ian edis who's a
colleague of mine at stanford uh is a
world expert in meta now it's probably
the most cited scientist on earth i
think
at least living
he he did a a meta-analysis of now a
hundred or more of these sarah
prevalence studies
and
what he found was that that point two
percent is roughly the worldwide
number i mean in fact i think you cites
this lower number point one five percent
as the median infection fatality rate
worldwide
so we did these studies and it generated
an enormous amount of blowback
by people who thought that the
infectious high rate is much higher
and there's some controversy over the
quality of some of the other studies
that that are done and so there are some
people who look at this same literature
and say well the the lower quality
studies tend to have lower ifrs
the higher quality studies so far oh
infection fatality right i apologize i
do this in lectures too
and i'm going to rudely interrupt you
and ask for uh for the basics sometimes
if it's okay no of course so these these
higher quality studies they say are
pretend to produce higher but the
problem is that
if you want a global infection fatality
rate you need to get
zero problem studies from everywhere
even places that don't necessarily have
the infrastructure set up to produce
very very high quality studies
and in poor places in the world
the the stu that like places like africa
the infection fatality rate is
incredibly low
uh and in some richer places
like new york city the infection
fatality rate is is much higher
it's there's a range of ifrs not a
single number
this sometimes surprises people because
they think well it's a it's a virus it
should have the same properties no
matter where it goes but the virus
kills or infects or hurts in interaction
with the host
and the properties of both the host and
the virus
combine to produce the the outcome but
you also mentioned the environment too
uh well it's i'm thinking mainly just
about the the person like if i'm gonna
think about like the most simplest way
to think about it is age age is the
single most important risk factor
so older places are going to have a
higher ifr
than younger places africa three percent
of africa is over 65
so in some sense it's not surprising
that they have a low infection fatality
rate so that's one way you would explain
the difference between africa and new
york city in terms of the fatality rate
is the age the average age yeah and
especially in the early days of the
epidemic in new york city
the
older populations living in nursing
homes were differentially infected
based on because of policies that were
adopted right to send
coveted infected patients back to
nursing homes to keep hospitals empty
what do you mean by differentially
infected
the policy that you adopt determines who
is most exposed
right that okay so that's what it is the
policy
it's the person that matters
i mean it's not like the virus just kind
of it doesn't care i mean the policy
determines the nature of the interaction
and there's also i mean there is some
contribution from the
environment
different regions have different
proximity maybe of people
interacting or the dynamics of the way
they interact
like if you have a if you have
situations where there's lots of
intergenerational
interactions yeah then you have a very
different risk profile than if than if
you have societies that are where
generations are more separate from one
another
um
okay so let me just finish real fast
about this so you you you have in new
york you have a population that was
infected in the early days that was
very likely going to die but had a much
higher likelihood of dying if infected
and so new york city had a higher ifr
especially in the early days than um
than um then like africa has had
the other thing is treatment right so
the treatments that we adopted in the
early days the epidemic i think actually
may have exacerbated the risk of death
which uh so like
using ventilators like the the over
reliance on ventilators is what i'm
primarily thinking of but i can think of
other things
um but that that uh also we've learned
over time how better to manage patients
with the disease
so you have those you have all those
things combined so that's that's where
the controversy over this over this
number is i mean
new york city
also it is a is a central hub for those
who tweet
and uh those who write
powerful stories and narratives in
article form
and i remember those quite dramatic
stories about sort of doctors in the
hospitals and these kinds of things i
mean
there's very serious very dramatic very
tragic deaths going on always in
hospitals those stories
um
a lot of loved ones losing each other on
a deathbed that's always tragic and you
can always write a hell of a good story
about that and you should
about the loss of loved ones but they
were doing it pretty pretty well i would
say um over this kind of dramatic
deaths and so in response to that it's
very
unpleasant to hear even to consider the
possibility that um the death rate is
not as high as you might otherwise as
you might feel
yeah i was surprised by the reaction
both by regular people and also the
scientific community in response to
those studies those early studies in
april of 2020 um uh to me they uh they
were they were studies i mean they're
they're the kinds of
not exactly the kind of work i've worked
on all my life but it's kind of kind of
like the kind of you know like you you
write a paper
and you get response responses from your
fellow scientists and you you know
change the paper to improve it you have
you hopefully learn something from it
well but to push back it's just a study
but there's some studies and this is
kind of interesting because i've
received similar pushback on other
topics
there's
some studies that
if
wrong might have a wide ranging
detrimental effects on society so that
that's the way they would perceive the
studies if you say the death rate is
lower and you end up as you often do in
science realizing that nope that this
that was there was a flaw in the way the
study was conducted or were just not
representative of a broader population
and then you realize the death rate is
much higher that might be very damaging
in in people's view uh so so that's
probably
where the scientific community sort of
just steel man the kind of response is
that's where they felt like you know
there's some findings where you better
be damn sure before you kind of report
them
yeah i mean we were pretty sure we were
right and it turns out we were right so
like when we so um
we released the the santa clara study
via this open open science process and
this
server called met archive it's it's
designed for releasing studies have not
yet been peer reviewed in order to
garner comment from the from the
scientists before peer review
the the la county study we went through
the traditional peer review process
and got it published in the journal of
american medical association sometime in
like
july i think forget the date of 2020.
the santa clara study released in april
of 2020 in this you know sort of working
paper archive
the the reason was that we felt we had
an obligation we had a result that was
we thought was quite important
and we wanted to tell the scientific
community about it and also tell the
world about it
and it wasn't we wanted to get feedback
i mean
that's part of the purpose of sending it
to these kinds of places
i think a lot of the problem is that
uh when people think about published
science they think of it as
automatically true and if it goes
through peer review it's automatically
true if it hasn't gone through peer
review it's not automatically true and
especially in medicine when we're not
used to having this at this access to
pre-peer-reviewed
work i mean in economics actually that's
quite normal you it takes years to get
something published so there's a very
active debate over or discussion about
papers before they're peer-reviewed in
this in this sort of working paper way
much less normal or much much newer in
in medicine
and so i think part of that the
perception about what those that that
what process happens in open science
when you release a study
that that got people confused and you're
right it was a very important result
because we had just locked the world
down in middle of march
with i think catastrophic results
and if the if that study was right if
our study was right that meant we'd made
a mistake
and not because the death rate was low
that's actually not the key thing there
the key thing is that we had adopted
these policies
these tests and trace policies these
policies these lockdown policies aimed
at suppressing the virus level to close
to zero that was essentially the idea
if we can just get the virus to go away
we won't have to ever worry about it
again
the main problem with our result as far
as that strategy was concerned wasn't
the death rate it was the 40 to 50 times
more infections than cases it was the
two and a half percent or
three percent or four percent prevalence
rate
that we identified
of the antibodies in the population if
that number is right it's too late the
virus is not going to go to zero
and no matter how much we test and trace
and isolate we're not going to get the
viral level down to zero
so we're going to have to
let the virus go through the entire
population in some way or so normally
well we can talk about that in a bit
that's the great barrington declaration
you don't have to let the virus go
through the population you can shield
preferentially the policy we chose was
to shield preferentially the the laptop
class
the set of people who could work from
home
without losing their job
yeah and we did a very good job at
protecting them well let me um
take a small tangent we're going to jump
around in time
which i think will be the best way to
tell the story so that was the beginning
yeah okay actually can i kind of go back
one more thing for that because that's
really important and i should have i
should have started with this
what led me to do those studies
was a paper that i'd remembered seeing
from the h1n1 flu epidemic in 2009 this
is where i've been much less active in
writing about that i've written up like
a paper or two about that when i in in
um
there there was actually this same
debate over the mortality rate
except it unfolded over the course of
three years two or three years the early
studies
of the mortality rate in h1n1 counted
the number of cases
in the denominator kind of the number of
deaths in the numerator cases meaning
people identified as having h1n1 showing
up the doctor
you know tested to have it
um and the early estimates of the h1n1
mortality were like four percent three
percent really really high
over the course of a couple of more
years a whole bunch of sierra prevalence
studies zero prevalence studies of h1n1
flu came out
and it turned out that there were
a hundred or more times
of people infected per case
and so the mortality rate was actually
something like 0.02 percent
for h1n1 not the three three
like a hundredfold difference so this
made you think
okay it took us a couple of two to three
years to discover the truth behind the
actual infections
uh for a h1n1 and then
what's the truth here and can we get
there faster yeah and there was it
spreads in a similar way as the as the
h1n1 flu did i mean it spreads the air
solization via you know so person person
breathing kind of kind of contact up um
and maybe maybe some by by phone mice
but it seems like that's less likely now
in any case it seemed really important
to me to speed up the process of having
those zero prevalence studies
so we can better understand who was at
risk
and what the right strategy ought to be
you